(suspenseful music)
(horn blares)
(crowd applauds)
(camera shutter clicks)
- [Johnny] The US government
is quietly reshaping the global economy
in ways that will change
our world forever.
(tense music)
You can see this in just one sentence
from Joe Biden's first
address to Congress.
(Congress applauding)
- Think about it,
there is simply no reason why
the blades for wind turbines
can't be built in Pittsburgh
instead of Beijing.
No reason, no reason, none.
(Congress applauds)
- [Johnny] This seems just
like a boring political statement,
but I promise this statement
is a bigger deal than it seems
because it marks a new
era in our global system,
a system that all of us participate in,
whether we know it or not,
or maybe it's a rerun
of an economic system
that the globe turned to right
before the Second World War.
- There's no reason why
American workers can't lead
the world in the production
of electric vehicles and batteries.
I mean, there is no reason.
We have the capacity.
(Congress applauds)
(tense music)
(machine flutters)
- [Johnny] In this video, I
want to peek under the hood
of the endlessly complex and
fascinating global economy,
to show you just how deeply
connected we've all become
and how those connections
are being cut and weaponized.
All of this thanks to
new threats, new risks,
new realizations, new values,
and above all, a new rivalry
between two great powers.
This is the world that we are moving into.
It's how things will
work for decades to come,
and it's important that we understand it.
(suspenseful music)
So let me give you an overview
of what is becoming
the new global economy.
- The new tariffs from both sides
went into effect earlier this morning.
- [Reporter] The US
tariffs have kicked in.
- China can't put as many tariffs on us
as we can put on them.
- China is still the biggest
threat to the United States.
(tense music)
- [Biden] Folks, we
need to make these chips
right here in America.
- Hey, so for a long time I've
been at war with marketers,
people who call my phone, even
though I don't want them to,
and who send me emails,
even though I never gave
them my email address.
We're all familiar with this.
It's called spam, and it
is increasingly a problem.
But then I recently learned
that I actually have the right
to request that I be taken
off of all of the lists
that people use to buy
and sell my information.
The problem is, even though
I have all these rights,
I'm not gonna go through the process
of like requesting a formal
like removal of my name
off of every one of these hundreds
of data broker lists that I'm on.
Incogni is the sponsor of today's video,
which is why I'm talking about this.
I'm very grateful to them for
supporting our journalism.
I signed up for Incogni,
and I gave them permission
to act on my behalf
to go take my name off
of data broker lists,
and then they start the
process of requesting
that your name be taken off.
Some of these companies are kind of shady
and they like try to push back,
and Incogni takes the time to follow up
and push until you are
taken off that list.
The best part is you get
to watch the progress
all on this nice dashboard
that tells you what lists your
name has been taken off of.
I recently learned just how pervasive
these data broker lists are.
Like, they use it not only
to like fill up your inbox with spam,
but also to like track
your web browsing activity,
which they then can sell to
like a health insurance company,
which could like jack up your premiums.
Luckily, Incogni has helped
strip me away from these lists,
and my phone is now strangely quiet.
My inbox is not a hornet's nest.
So if you wanna try this out,
there's a link in my description.
It is incogni.com/johnnyharris.
When you click the link, you
get a pretty big discount.
It's like 60% off when you
sign up for the annual plan.
I do the annual plan
because once you're taken off these lists,
you immediately get put back on,
and Incogni constantly
monitors month after month
to make sure that you
stay off these lists.
So yeah, big discount.
Click the link in my description,
use the code, and you'll
get the big discount.
You can try it out and see if
it clears your life of spam
and makes you feel like you
have a little more privacy
in your life.
Let's dive into this story.
It's a big one, it's an important one,
and I'm excited to share it with you.
(mysterious music)
The economy that we live in,
that we all take for granted,
is actually relatively new.
The clothes that you're
wearing right now, the computer
or the phone that you're
looking at to watch this video,
the materials that your
house is made out of,
the fibers in the blanket
that you use at night,
the food you eat, all of it is a product
of perhaps one of the most
significant achievements
of our species: global trade.
(mysterious music)
(camera shutter clicking)
Early on, humans discovered
the magic that occurs
when a group of people specialize
in producing something
valuable like grain.
They make more than they need,
and then they take that excess
and they give it to another group
who also made too much of something
because they specialize in a
specific thing, maybe textiles.
And through this exchange,
both parties benefit way more
than they could on their own.
It was this kind of cooperation
that leveled our species up
beyond any other animal on Earth.
So we just kept doing it.
In fact, the history of
our human civilization
is largely the history of people trading
on an ever-growing scale.
Today, this is normal.
We call it the economy.
By the time the 1900s rolled around,
we had a pretty connected world.
There was global trade all over the place,
but it was still pretty clunky.
Everyone had different trade
rules, different currencies.
Countries were worried that
foreign products would threaten
their domestic producers, so
they put up trade barriers
and imposed big tariffs on
stuff coming into their country.
Then, 70 years, ago came that war
that almost tore this world apart.
(explosions thunder)
(engines rumble)
Out of the ashes of that war,
the US emerged as the most
powerful country ever.
It had troops and influence
in every corner of the globe.
And with that new power,
the US and its allies wrote a new playbook
for the world economy.
(dollar sign chimes)
They would make it so that the US dollar
was the top currency.
Everything would kind of
be pegged to the US dollar.
This helped stabilize the whole system.
It helped it move more predictably.
It helped countries send and
receive money across borders.
The US also got countries together
with the goal of lowering
the taxes imposed
on products flowing in and
out of their country: tariffs.
And through all these efforts,
all these new rules, borders opened up.
Investors could put their
money almost anywhere on Earth
to grow new businesses.
Corporations could look to far away lands
for cheaper workers to
set up their factories.
The world became one big market,
and it started to benefit
hundreds of millions of people.
(bright music)
So much so that even
anti-capitalist China couldn't stay
out of this global economy that
was so unrecognizably open,
that was so much more open
than anything the world had ever seen.
There was way too much money
to be made, so China jumped in.
They said that they
would remain communists,
but they would open up a few
dozen of their coastal cities
to be open for business
in this new global market.
Millions of China's rural poor flocked
to the coastal cities, these
gateways to the global market.
They showed up ready to
work, and to work for cheap.
A world away, over in the United States,
corporations looked at
all of their factories
in places like Detroit and Buffalo,
and realized that it would
make a lot more sense
for them to move all of
these factories to China
where they could pay workers
a fraction of the wage.
And, spoiler alert, all
these coastal cities in China
that opened up to the global
economy soon looked like this.
Hundreds of millions of
people in China lifted out
of poverty and thrust into this
new middle and upper class,
all thanks to the magic
of the global economy
based on the rules and policies
that the US had set up after World War II.
It was so good for China and
a bunch of other countries,
but for the many Americans
whose jobs had just been given
to someone in like Shanghai,
this didn't feel like magic.
It felt like betrayal,
like a recipe for poverty and ghost towns.
(haunting music)
This China shock was one
of the first big tastes
of the economic pain that this
global economy could inflict
on huge numbers of people.
But to everyone else,
it was totally worth it,
because thanks to this system,
people were suddenly seeing
prices at their stores
drop further than seemed possible.
Washing machines, shoes,
tools, toasters, couches,
shirts, socks, toys,
mattresses, lawn chairs,
anything you can think of is now flowing
from Chinese factories
and available for dirt
cheap at your local Walmart,
all while transforming the lives of people
in places like Vietnam,
India, Chile, and Thailand,
who saw huge economic
growth during these years.
So by the '80s, China's
fully in the global economy,
and it is a gravy train.
The US and UK both elect leaders
who love this free-trade
global capitalism.
- More trade, not less is
the wave of the future.
- The new system was boosted
by all of this new technology
that was coming out,
making it easier to pass
information across borders,
to move money, to move people,
to move goods across the globe.
A globe.
Promise to obey.
If we all believe and obey these rules,
it creates the conditions
that made the world into
a giant marketplace,
where a corporation could
source whatever they needed
to make their product from
anywhere in the world,
whatever made the most economic sense.
Soon, products as simple as a T-shirt
would travel along an
unfathomably complex supply chain,
using material and labor
from many countries all around the globe,
before eventually showing up conveniently
just in time at the store.
Policy had created mass
cooperation between billions
of people who don't
speak the same language,
who don't know each other,
but are somehow all getting
in on the same market.
This mental construct of economic policy
is what created globalization,
the globalization we know today.
And what's crazy to me is that,
if you tinker with the
policy, if you mess with this,
you can reverse a lot
of this globalization,
which is exactly what's
happening right now.
- There is simply no reason why
the blades for wind turbines
can't be built in Pittsburgh
instead of Beijing.
- Okay, but let's stick
to our timeline here.
We're kind of in the '90s.
And I'll tell you, people in
the '90s would've never guessed
what direction this story is about to go.
The Soviet Union had just fallen,
free trade and global capitalism
had unambiguously beat communism,
and the magic of the free
market was seen as the solution
for pretty much everything.
Free trade had just ended global conflict
between these great
superpowers, maybe forever.
Free trade was eradicating global poverty.
Free trade was pushing
countries to adopt democracy.
And here's Bill Clinton,
giddy about how good it's all going,
predicting that free trade
would bring democracy to China.
- The more China liberalizes its economy,
the more fully it will liberate
the potential of its people,
their initiative, their imagination,
their remarkable spirit of enterprise.
And when individuals have
the power not just to dream,
but to realize their dreams,
they will demand a greater say.
- Free trade would prevent
our age-old human curse, war,
by so deeply entangling countries
in mutually beneficial deals
that it wouldn't make sense to fight.
After all, free trade had turned Europe
from a continent ravaged by
war to this tightly-knit group
where everyone's holding
hands and smiling together.
Why wouldn't this naturally
just happen to the whole globe?
China continued to make stuff
and send it to the United States.
Our dependency on them and
them on us continue to grow,
and that would surely
prevent any conflict, right?
Um, no.
(deflated music)
It's looking like that's
not how it's gonna turn out.
In fact, it's kind of the opposite.
- The new tariffs from both sides
went into effect earlier this morning.
The US has imposed 10% tariffs
on $200 billion worth of Chinese imports.
- China is our military's
most consequential strategic
competitor and pacing challenge.
- In a relatively sudden shift,
governments around the
world are undoing a lot
of this globalization, this
solution to all of our problems.
They're rejecting it.
India is paying companies
to keep their production
within their own borders,
especially for important industries
like pharmaceuticals and electronics.
South Korea is giving
taxpayer money to companies
to produce green energy infrastructure
instead of waiting for the
free market to come build it.
Japan is paying companies to
move production back to Japan
and to move their supply
chains away from China.
Australia is using taxpayer money
to encourage mining companies
to establish the processing
of rare-earth mineral
facilities within their borders
instead of abroad.
Nigeria is imposing
restrictions on foreign goods
that they want to see
produced domestically,
like rice and cement.
They don't wanna be
reliant on other countries.
And then you've got Europe,
where tons of countries are
investing government money
and protecting homegrown industries
that have always been directed
by the global economy,
like energy, agriculture, and cars.
The government getting
involved in these markets
incentivizes companies
and consumers to make
and sell these products in country
as opposed to looking
abroad at the global market.
And of course, leading out on all of this
is the OG of the modern
free-market global economy,
the United States, who is
suddenly changing course
from how they've been operating,
all the way up until like Obama.
Like, Obama spent a great deal of his time
trying to increase free
trade, especially with Asia.
Then, first under Trump
and now under Biden,
the US is overhauling its economic policy
to turn back some of this free trade.
And what's crazy is that both Republicans
and Democrats seem to agree
that we should do this and fast.
(upbeat music)
- There is no reason.
We have the capacity.
(Congress applauds)
- Some of these policies
include huge government
spending bills, like the CHIPS Act,
which would allocate over 50
billion government dollars
to companies that produce microchips
here in the United States,
instead of in Asia,
where the free market had
pulled them to set up.
This is also happening in other industries
that the government has deemed vital,
like critical minerals,
cars, and clean energy.
But they're not just giving subsidies,
like, it's not just
government money washing down
on all these industries,
it's also barriers.
Biden is imposing tariffs on imports,
which protects domestic
producers of certain industries
because they no longer have to compete
with the global market.
They're also banning American companies
from selling certain products to China.
They're increasing
scrutiny on any investment
that comes in from places like China.
Like, this is a big shift.
And the question is, what happened?
How did we get from this free-trade heyday
that was supposed to usher
in world peace to this?
(upbeat music)
- Markets have been whipsawed all morning,
and now afternoon, by this
ongoing trade war with China.
- The short answer is one word,
the answer to all of this: protection.
Here's my list of four protections
that best explain this big
shift in economic policy.
(mysterious music)
First, workers,
which we already kind
of talked about briefly
with the China shock.
For all the winners of the global economy,
there were lots of losers,
and a lot of them were communities
who found themselves out of work
as their jobs went to
cheaper overseas locations.
Now listen, economists argue as to how big
of a problem this actually was,
and you can read all
about it in my sources,
but the point is that closed factories
and unemployed communities
in the Rust Belt
have a major psychological
effect on people
who fear that their jobs
might just disappear,
either abroad or be taken over by AI.
So the government is
trying to calm people down
by pumping money into certain sectors
to keep jobs in America.
The next big realization
about the global economy:
It doesn't really care much
about how much carbon it
pumps into our atmosphere.
Our world is barreling towards
a very real climate crisis,
and governments realize they're gonna have
to force the market to get serious
about things like electric
cars, solar panels,
and other green infrastructure.
The free market is not
going to incentivize this.
And if it doesn't happen,
we're gonna have a much
bigger problem on our hands.
(mysterious music)
One of the best parts
of the global economy
is that our products get made by materials
that are being tossed around
the globe at the perfect time,
at the perfect place, to all come together
to be made into a final product,
all to arrive at a shelf at some store
so that we can purchase it.
These supply chains are insane,
and they cross the entire planet.
And it works great
until the world shut down
in a global pandemic,
leaving people around the world
without the products
that they either needed
or just kinda got used to having.
Again, economists argue about
how big of a deal this was.
A lot of them are like,
"No, the supply chains held
up really well during COVID."
But regardless of what some
academic economist is saying
at MIT, all of us are left
with a pretty bad taste
in our mouth about supply
chains after COVID.
The system feels too fragile.
A lot of us feel too
reliant on a fragile system
of far away global connections
that could be rocked at any moment,
which has led to these
protectionist policies
that these governments hope
will bring supply chains back
inside of their borders.
Okay, finally, and perhaps
the most important explanation
in all of this, is that Bill
Clinton was totally wrong.
Free trade didn't incentivize China
into a democratic revolution.
The world did not join together
in one big free-trade market,
too entangled to fight with each other.
In fact, quite the opposite has happened.
- Relations between the
world's two largest economies
are at their most tense in years.
- After joining the global economy,
China got really rich really fast.
They've kind of started to
challenge the US at its own game,
and now they have one of
the biggest militaries
on the planet, and they use that military
to assert their influence
around their region.
They use their newfound wealth
to project influence around the world
by building stuff or
giving loans to people.
And they're kind of trying
to dethrone the United States
as the one who's calling the shots
on the global economic order.
I made a whole video about this
that you can go watch if you want,
but the big point here
is that the US is worried
about the rapid rise of
their rival across the ocean,
especially when the rise of that rival
is in part fueled by American technology,
specifically these little
silicon chips, microchips,
that make weapons smart,
and that will be the brains
that power the AI revolution.
A lot of Joe Biden's
protectionist policies
are actually just aimed right at China,
trying to stop them
from using our own tech
to get ahead of us.
Again, I made an entire
video about microchips.
You can go to that.
I've kind of made a video
about a lot of these things.
But yeah, Joe Biden is also
trying to get the supply chains
for these microchips out
of China's neighborhood,
meaning out of Taiwan, bringing
them back inside our borders
to places like New Albany, Ohio,
nice and safe in the
middle of our continent.
So you're gonna see a lot
more moments like this
with American presidents or
politicians with hard hats on,
speaking at construction sites.
- Folks, we need to make these
chips right here in America
to bring down everyday
cost and create good jobs.
America's back, and
America's leading the way.
(tense music)
- This last point is kind
of a brutal recognition
for a lot of people,
including me, to be honest,
that our theory that we
would all be more peaceful
if we were more economically
entangled is kind of wrong,
at least for now.
In fact, these economic
entanglements are looking
like they might turn
into tools of conflict
as opposed to preventers of conflict.
Like, China has a near monopoly on a lot
of the rare-earth elements
that we need to make a ton
of very important products,
including military weapons.
And if push comes to shove,
they could very realistically
use this as leverage
and cut us off in the exact same way
that we cut them off microchips.
I mean, this just happened.
Vladimir Putin turned off the pipelines
that pumped natural gas into Europe,
the gas that is needed to heat the homes
and run the factories,
showing us that economic entanglements
can actually be a weapon,
and flipping this whole
theory on its head.
But yeah, Joe Biden is pouring money
into bringing production home,
and he has a lot of support
from all sides of the aisle.
So it's like economic nationalism.
The government is getting
involved to undo some
of what the free market did in its heyday,
which was to distribute
production of stuff
where it made the most economic sense,
not where it protected people.
- That means we will invent it in America
and make it in America,
and we're gonna make sure
we include all of America.
- So that's where we're at.
The world is reacting to
some weaknesses that they see
in the global free-trade system.
They're putting up barriers
in the name of protection.
And no one's really sure what that means.
Like, it's kind of hard
to not look at this
and draw some parallels with the 1930s
when a series of economic
crises led countries
to put up trade barriers
in the name of protection,
which then led to ever
greater economic strife,
leading to unrest and
eventually culminating
in the Second World War.
(deflated music)
But don't read too far into that.
I'm not trying to like
do one of those things
where I'm like, "Every hundred years,
history repeats itself."
That's not what I think is happening here.
But there's some similarities
that we should probably
just keep an eye on.
A suite of crises that
make us turn inward,
that surge populism and
economic nationalism
and the rise of tensions
between great powers.
(bright music)
Hey, before you go, I need
to tell you one last thing,
which is that we made
probably our last batch
of the poster that I designed last year.
It's a poster called "All Maps Are Wrong,"
and I'm very proud of it.
It shows all the ways that
you can take our Earth
and project it onto a 2D plane,
which always comes with some distortion.
Anyway, it's kind of a
nerdy map-lover thing,
and if you're into that, you
should go over and check it out
before they're all gone.
This is probably gonna be our last batch,
so get 'em while they last,
and the link's in the description.